il faut se mettre d'accord sur ce que
c'est que le capitalisme il ya beaucoup
de définitions qui circulent celle qu'on
discute un peu dans notre livre à
l'éphédrine
c'est la suivante c'est ils ont un
mouvement qui sauve qui s'origine au
nord de l'italie au 14e siècle
c'est un syndrome de banquiers qui pour
la première fois pratique cette
opération symbolique extrêmement
puissant qui consiste à transformer
quelque chose dans la capitale qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un capital c'est une
marchandise qui doit rapporter des
revenus un flux de revenus dans l'avenue
flux de revenus qu'on doit pouvoir être
capable de d'estimer à l'avance pour
pouvoir mesurer la valeur de ce capital
aujourd'hui alors ça c'est une pratique
extrêmement répandu en finance
aujourd'hui sa peine l'actualisation
donc par exemple calculer le prix d'une
obligation vous dites voilà cette
obligation d'en rapporter un flux de ce
qu'on appelait cash flow dans l'avenir
vous les escompté avec un taux
d'escompté est en général et eliane taux
d'intérêt et ça vous donne la valeur
actuelle de l'obligation
mais en réalité cette opération est
extrêmement puissante et extrêmement
destructrice parce que la partie moment
où vous vous autorisez à tout
transformer en capital à tous
capitaliser alors vous pouvez décider
qu'une forêt du capital pourrait décider
que le ventre d'une femme c'est une
capitale pour éviter que le corps humain
et du capital et s'est arrêté que l'adn
est un capital et dans ce cas là vous
transformer tout en ressources destinées
à produire des revenus futurs pour vous
vous abolissez le rapport au temps
puisque vous exigez que vous connaissiez
à l'avance le flux des revenus records
qu'on va me rapporter un capital et vous
avez un rapport qui a principalement
destructeur au reste du monde donc c'est
ça qui aujourd'hui est remis en cause à
mon avis à cause d' explosion des
inégalités et à cause du désastre
écologique
[Musique]